Jabril thanks for joining us
congratulations how you feeling today
I'm good thank you guys having his life
changed at all for you know it's been
the same same old same old for the most
part harder I just kind of lay low as
possible who what position do you think
you're gonna play in the NFL or do you
want to play in the NFL
safety safety money backers
things like that what is the money it's
the money backer it's like kind of like
a specialized hybrid linebacker safety I
think that they're becoming quite the
norm in the lead now
with all these new defensive schemes and
stuff so you know that's where I see
myself fit in there I like to call it
the Kam Chancellor position how's that
that's a great name for it
give me your official height and weight
basically I'm probably 511 and six foot
is about 208 so 210 now why is the
program say you're 6:1 Jabril you know I
liked it in high school just so I can
you know get a scholarship but what I'm
totally changing once I got there
because it's going
they got no to choose anyway when the
time comes so I'm not I'm not do when
one of the guys who likes to lie about
their get high weight you know cuz I
don't think that matters personally if
you can ball you could ball so what was
your second choice if Michigan wasn't
the place where were you going and what
made Michigan the place to go Michigan a
lot of the great waiters grew up loving
the helmets tough one like the one of
the first things that caught my
attention was they have really cool
helmet
[Music]
and you know I it was the best it was
the best opportunity for sports in an
academic you know Stanford was up there
to the Stanford was across the country
and I didn't want to go that far away my
family
Oh a jewel it was I could I could I
couldn't play couldn't play with that
heat it was a different kind of hot but
other than that you know I loved it and
I liked Michigan because you know you it
was it was kind of like New Jersey in
terms of the weather yeah I got to go to
this summer was really hard and you got
you know the fall or winter you know so
I enjoy the cold too so you know it's
kind of a no-brainer for me especially I
took my Lizzie knows everything I could
have wanted so you know it was
definitely no brainer Valley what was
your reaction the first time you saw
Harbaugh med Harbaugh oh wow you know I
also used to seeing them on TV no
yelling on a San Francisco skyline so
you know I was just curious to how he
was gonna do here in you know he's done
a great great job know putting us in
positions to excelling turning the
program around you see funny yeah yeah
very funny
yeah but it also what you see is who he
is
I doesn't put on any threats or anything
for TV and that's one of the main things
I love about it know what you guys are
you guys allowed to do a Harbaugh
impersonation I'll probably say I don't
think he would mind but you could make
fun of him oh that's right that's right
okay all right you you could you could
be late why would you stay no Tata Tata
finish the month finish things here you
know to keep their better working on my
cry
you know I don't know man to make but
I'm I'm not even I'm not even hey you
know what you're saying all the right
things and then we'll see you in in the
draft it's okay you know don't worry
about it I know what you're doing we're
gonna keep it quiet all right yeah we
got we're just gonna keep this on them
on the on the down-low who would you
vote for for Heisman it'll be out of the
water or lamar d wat won that game you
know so I applaud you for my vote you
know whatever you have whenever you have
two Heisman finalist faces and one
another no it was a very very good game
you know uh at the end of the day you
know the show washes they came away with
the victory so you know that's why I
definitely Marvel to be stupid even
though you can't even though you can't
knock with Lamar Jackson has done well
with what is amazing season you know but
I think that loss to Clemson and their
loss to uh was in Kentucky
yeah really hurt him other than that man
you know he's been he's been a catalyst
up this team you know they go as far as
he does so you know okay you can't knock
that either it's gonna be real real
tricky but you know I definitely say
those those two guys or depakote Easter
Brill Peppers Michigan linebacker will
play in the NFL next year joining us on
the Dan Patrick show do you have your
outfit picked out for Saturday night me
Heisman ceremony I do I do this is gonna
be crazy
um this shouldn't be too crazy you know
zombies
nice nice nice and simple with a good a
little flavor to it yeah you're gonna
have any Michigan colors in there a
little bit maybe a like a pocket square
or something or here's my word words of
advice is make sure you go clean because
10 years from now 15 years from now when
they look back and they go you were
in that like you don't want that okay
yeah just a nice crisp you like nice
blue suit nice bright tie you know that
that's that's the way to go now here's
the here's the final question for you
Jabril if now be honest if Harbaugh
fought Urban Meyer in the Octagon what
happens for always under six really how
did this it yeah I won't win hunts
percent
it's a side saying you guys no no we
know it we've seen it you know he's a
guy who will do whatever it takes away I
got I got a pool foot I got pool by my
coach oh now you like he would bite he
would be even fight dirty
hey do whatever he has to do with that's
how you coaches yeah that's I should go
fight are you are you over the Ohio
state laws no I'm never over a loss
until we win the game so you know we
putting on a lark our focus in
preparation it's at his Orange Bowl with
a very good as you change and you know
last year we know we we prepared the
right way and took care of business
against water so you know they're gonna
hope for the same formula this year can
you catch Dalvin cook anything up that
know that catching yeah
that's the fun thing you don't have to
go well maybe if I ever played against
him you get to play against him that'll
be a whole lot of fun hey congrats it
was a lot of fun to watch you this year
and good luck against Florida State we
appreciate it
alright Jarell peppers Michigan
linebacker money backer the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
you